en el último vídeo aprendimos un poquito
de lo que eran las moléculas quirales y
lo que eran carbonos quirales átomos
finales y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es ir e ir más que nada a hacer
varios ejemplos y ver si podemos
identificar si hay algunos átomos
quirales y también si estamos trabajando
con moléculas quirales así que vamos a
ver algunos ejemplos que tengo por aquí
digamos vamos a empezar con estos dos y
tenemos este primero que es el cloruro
de ciclo ventana verdad justamente
tenemos un cloro unido a una cadena
principal digamos de 5 átomos de carbono
entonces la pregunta es si esta molécula
de entrada tiene algún centro quiral o
algún átomo que irá al verdad y la
respuesta la podemos dar fijándonos por
ejemplo en cualquiera de estos ch2
primero digamos podríamos pensar que en
realidad no está este h2 sino que está
unido a una h y a otro h y además está
unido a estos grupos se h dos verdad
entonces inmediatamente uno puede decir
que estos carbonos que se encuentran
digamos en estas
en esta cadena principal no no son
átomos quirales o no son centros finales
ya que están unidos a dos hidrógenos y
podríamos pensar que son dos grupos
sustituye entes iguales verdad entonces
en realidad ninguno de estos carbonos
que se encuentran digamos que son parte
de algún se h dos por ejemplo este-oeste
o este-oeste ninguno de estos cuatro
puede ser un centro quiral entonces
nuestra única opción podría ser que sea
este carbono de aquí entonces podríamos
eliminar digamos este hidrógeno y
ponerlo de esta forma y vemos que este
carbono está unido a un cloro está unido
a un hidrógeno pero está unido digamos a
todo este ciclo entonces podríamos
digamos dividir como a la mitad verdad y
si nos vamos hacia la izquierda
o bueno digamos más bien hacia arriba
verdad sería más correcto decir en
contra de las manecillas del reloj
podemos ver que tenemos como este
este grupo verdades de sh2 unido a un ch
2 y si nos vamos en la dirección de las
manecillas del reloj podemos ver que
estamos unidos también a 2 c h 2 verdad
y al mismo tiempo están unidos entre
ellos es decir si si le damos toda la
vuelta tenemos un ch 2 unido a ch 2 se h
12 h 2 y regresamos a donde empezamos si
nos vamos en la dirección de las
manecillas del reloj
tendremos que h 12 h 12 h 12 h 2 y
regresamos al punto donde iniciamos
entonces realmente podríamos pensar que
que este no es un centro que ir al este
no es
no es un centro quiral
centro ir al y otra vez podríamos ver
justamente como que está unido a los
mismos grupos verdad y de hecho también
podemos ver que no es una molécula que
irá al verdad es decir tendríamos que
comparar con respecto a su reflejo
digamos en un espejo entonces tendríamos
este cloro unido a éste ch que está
unido a 12h dos verdades tres se h 2c h
está unido algún ch2 unido
a otros se h dos unido al ch los muy
bien entonces digamos esta es la imagen
reflejada más o menos de este que
teníamos a la izquierda y podemos ver
que no es que irá al verdad nosotros
podríamos rotar esta esta molécula
digamos más o menos algo así en todo
este ángulo no es precisamente 180
grados verdad pero podríamos tratar de
hacer que éste se h terminará en esta
posición que es más o menos lo que se ve
aquí entonces qué es lo que tendríamos
tendríamos algo como déjenme déjenme
pintarlo en pequeños y ponemos este ese
h hasta acá
un ch unido a nuestro cloro de digamos
en este en este sentido y luego éste sh2
ch2 y luego estos unidos a los ch 2
de esta forma así se vería digamos y
rotamos esta molécula de tal suerte que
este carbono de aquí quede en esta
posición de acá verdad entonces uno
diría bueno en realidad no son tan
idénticos porque el cloro está hacia
abajo mientras que aquí está hacia
arriba bueno para en realidad pues
podría quitar esto así y ponerlo de esta
forma y podemos ver que justamente son
exactamente lo mismo verdad entonces
realmente podemos superponer estas dos
moléculas verdad podemos encimar las y
quedan exactamente igual entonces esta
molécula está no espiral
no es girar justamente porque podemos
rotarla y moverla para encimar la sobre
su imagen
digamos reflejada en el espejo verdad
vamos a ver otro ejemplo el siguiente
ejemplo es este de aquí abajo que se
parece mucho al al que hicimos en el
vídeo anterior que es el el bromo cloro
flúor o metano verdad este es el bromo
cloro flúor o metano entonces la
pregunta es si este este carbono del
centro es un centro girar y la respuesta
es que si verdad esto es muy fácil de
ver que esto es un centro girar
algo es un carbono final y eso es
justamente porque está unido a cuatro
grupos sustituye entes distintos bueno a
cuatro grupos distintos
tenemos unido a un flúor tenemos unido
un cloro y bromo y un hidrógeno entonces
este el bromo cloro floro metano tiene
como centro que irala este átomo de
carbono ahora si queremos ver si toda la
molécula es
espiral pues tendríamos que dibujar su
reflejo verdad entonces vamos a pintar
aquí digamos el espejo aquí tendríamos
el flúor
el carbono déjenme hacerlo con otro
color para para variar un poquito
tendríamos aquí en nuestro carbono aquí
nuestro
que estaría aquí estaría el cloro verdad
porque justo estamos reflejando y el
bromo estaría de este otro lado mientras
que el que el hidrógeno que va digamos
por atrás sigue en la misma posición
entonces realmente no podemos rotar esta
molécula o modificarla para poder
encimarlo en esta otra verdad si
nosotros quisiéramos por ejemplo encima
del bromo sería moverlo en esa dirección
hasta llegar a ésta entonces el cloro
ocuparía la posición del hidrógeno y el
hidrógeno la del bromo que justo no es
lo que vemos de este lado del espejo
verdad entonces ésta completita es una
molécula viral
la molécula que irá al verdad y su
centro que es este carbono
y de hecho hay todo un nombre para estas
dos versiones las dos versiones que se
encuentran separadas por el espejo
tenemos un nombre para estas ir y vamos
a entrar más en el digamos en este tipo
de nombres en en vídeos posteriores
porque es un poquito más complicado
vamos a tener todo un vídeo solito para
este tema pero estas dos versiones del
bromo cloro flúor o metano a veces
tienen propiedades químicas distintas y
por eso es que vamos a ponerle cierto
nombre y de hecho vamos a decir que son
en anti o menos
son en anti o menos muy bien
un enantiómero es justamente la imagen
reflejada de la otra verdad pero estos
también podemos decir que son estéreo
isómeros estos son también estéreo
so menos
y todo esto sólo es terminología de
hecho ya estamos familiarizados con la
palabra y somero un isómero simplemente
significa que tenemos los mismos átomos
en una molécula pero podríamos tener
distintos tipos de isómeros verdad
siempre tenemos y son menos
constitucionales en donde decimos que
aunque tenemos los mismos átomos en
realidad están conectados de forma
distinta
ahora los estéreo isómeros son digamos
las mismas los mismos las mismas
moléculas pero es pero están conectadas
de la misma forma si pensamos por
ejemplo en estos dos
si pensamos en estos dos están
conectados de la misma forma pero solo
tienen propiedades químicas distintas
debido a que una es reflexión sobre un
espejo digamos de la otra verdad
así que realmente solo son los mismos
objetos están conectados a las mismas
cosas pero tienen una configuración
tridimensional distinta y ahí es en
donde estamos lidiando digamos con el
estéreo verdad la parte estéreo de este
nombre
la estéreo química es el estudio digamos
de la química en tres dimensiones que es
realmente tratar de entender la
estructura tridimensional de las cosas
así que los exteriores son - significan
que tenemos los mismos constituyentes
podemos decir los mismos átomos tienen
las mismas conexiones entre ellos por
ejemplo aquí el bromo está conectado al
carbono que está conectado al cloro y el
carbono también al flúor en fin en
realidad tenemos las mismas conexiones
pero tenemos una estructura
tridimensional distinta verdad su
orientación todavía es distinta y en
este caso son imágenes reflejadas la una
de la de la otra y por eso es que les
llamamos enantiómero
y quizás este es un buen momento para
hacer una una aclaración en los vídeos
anteriores he utilizado los términos
configuración y a veces también he
utilizado la palabra conformación
entonces utilizado configuración
configuración y también he utilizado la
palabra conformación quizás debí haberlo
hecho con mucho más cuidado porque
cuando yo estoy hablando de una
configuración perdón cuando estamos
hablando de una configuración realmente
estamos hablando de una estructura
distinta por ejemplo si yo quiero
moverme de una configuración a otra
realmente por ejemplo tendría que romper
enlaces o reacomodarlos así que estos
dos son distintas configuraciones porque
yo tendría que reacomodar los enlaces
para poder llegar de una a la otra
verdad ahora en cambio cuando estamos
hablando de conformación y quizás lo que
más puede recordarte una conformación es
cuando hablábamos de las conformaciones
del ciclo hexano verdad podríamos decir
que el ciclo hexano tenía una
conformación
verdad ahí está la conformación bote o
podríamos pensar que tenía una
conformación silla y en realidad es la
misma molécula solo tiene con
formaciones distintas en realidad no
tuvimos que romper enlaces o
reacomodarlos simplemente tuvimos que
digamos moverla un poquito para llegar
de una conformación a la otra en cambio
con las configuraciones si tienes que
arreglar los enlaces muy bien ahora
vamos a fijarnos en este último ejemplo
tenemos esta molécula y vamos a ver si
podemos identificar centros corales y
ver si esta molécula es una molécula
quiral en sí misma entonces si nos
fijamos por ejemplo en este carbono
podemos notar que está unido aún a un
átomo de flúor y a otro átomo de carbono
pero arriba y abajo está unido
átomos de hidrógeno entonces podríamos
pensar que está unido a dos grupos
idénticos lo cual eso hace que este
carbono no sea un centro cuidad pero
vamos a ver qué pasa con el otro por
ejemplo qué pasa con este este está
unido a un carbono que además está unido
a un hidrógeno flor h digamos a un ch 2
efe verdad
y además está unido a un hidrógeno por
otro lado está unido a un cloro y
finalmente a un bromo entonces realmente
este carbono está unido a cuatro grupos
funcionales distintos verdades entonces
esto sería un centro viral muy bien y
uno podría inmediatamente pensar si esta
molécula espiral entonces tendríamos que
pintar su reflexión digamos al respecto
a esta línea digamos ok tendríamos aquí
el cloro el carbono el hidrógeno el
bromo
y el carbono otro hidrógeno flúor y otro
hidrógeno entonces uno podría
preguntarse si hay una forma de acomodar
esta molécula sobre esta de tal suerte
que que se empalmen digamos
y digamos para que pudieran empalmarse
tendríamos que rotar esta molécula
digamos como 180 grados de tal suerte
que el cloro se encima sobre este que
tenemos al del lado derecho pero el
hidrógeno en vez de quedar arriba
quedaría abajo entonces uno puede ver
fácilmente que estas son moléculas
quirales verdad justamente no podemos
empalme y empalmar las ya que son
reflexiones sobre este espejo así que ya
nos estamos pasando mucho de tiempo
vamos a ver un poco más de ejemplos en
el próximo vídeo